my Barris skin and had been rubbing
against the ground behind a dumpster
while on a raft freshman was humping my
half naked unconscious body
Your Honor if it is alright the majority
of this statement I would like to
address the defendant directly you don't
know me but you've been inside me and
that's why we're here today one day I
was at work
scrolling through the news on my phone
and came across an article in it I read
and learned for the first time about how
I was found unconscious with my hair
disheveled long necklace wrapped around
my neck bra pulled out of my dress dress
pulled off over my shoulders and pulled
up above my waist and I was butt-naked
all the way down to my boots legs spread
apart and have been penetrated by a
foreign object by someone I did not
recognize this is how I learned what
happened to me sitting at my desk
reading the news at work I learned what
happened to me the same time everyone
else in the world learned what happened
to me I kept reading in the next
paragraph I read something that I will
never forgive I read that according to
him I liked it I liked it again I do not
have words for these feelings sometimes
I think if I hadn't gone then this never
would have happened well then I realized
it would have happened just to somebody
else
my breasts had been groped fingers had
been jabbed inside me along with pine
needles and debris my bare skin it had
been rubbing against the ground behind a
dumpster while in a wrecked freshman was
humping my half naked unconscious body
but I don't remember so how do I prove I
didn't like it I was not only told that
I was assaulted I was told that because
I couldn't remember it technically could
not prove it was unwanted and that
distorted me damaged me almost broke me
the sexual assault had been so clear but
instead here I was the trial answering
questions like how old are you how much
do you weigh what did you have for
dinner did you drink with dinner
how much do you usually drink who
dropped you off at this party what were
you wearing was your phone on silent
when your sister called do you remember
silencing it really because on page 53
I'd like to point out that you said it
was said to ring you said you were a
party animal are you serious with your
boyfriend after a physical assault I was
assaulted with questions designed to
attack me to say see her facts don't
line up she's out of her mind she's
practically an alcoholic she probably
wanted to hook up he's like an athlete
right they were both drunk whatever I
don't sleep when I think about the way
it could have gone if those two guys had
never come what would have happened to
me that's what you'll never have a good
answer for that's what you can't explain
even after a year he has done
irreversible damage to me and my family
during the trial and we have sat
silently listening to him shape the
evening board in the end his
unsupportive statements and his
attorneys twisted logic fooled no one
the truth one the truth spoke for itself